hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we're going to
be looking at the opening the Danish
gambit in the Danish game it's probably
one of the most aggressive openings in
the game white starts out by sacrificing
two of its pawns in exchange for quick
development and very open attacking
lines right off the bat and the opening
hasn't been studied as much as other
openings so it's still debated whether
this is a good opening or not but we're
going to go ahead and take a look at
some of the lines and actually look at a
famous game that was played by it and
kind of look at how White was able to
exploit blacks lack of development for a
pretty easy win so we'll get into it it
starts out pawn to e4 black responds
pawn to e5 and white offers up first
sacrifice at pawn to d4 and when black
takes white sacrifices another pawn here
on c3 and when black takes white is
going to play Bishop to
see for now obviously as you can tell at
any time white could have taken these
but this is part of the Danish gambit
and right off the bat white is starting
to attack he's already put his bishop on
c4 eyeing the f7 square which is a huge
weakness for black and is going to try
to exploit that later on in the game
vacu black usually continues to just
keep capturing pawns trying to go up
more material and black or excuse me
white is going to come in and finally
take this pawn and as he does you can
see that why it's already started
attacking with a lot of this pieces on
the blacks King side and as you can see
all of black's pieces on his back rank
have not moved
he has no peace beyond the seventh rank
here and white already has two bishops
in place and he has a nice little center
control with his white pawn here so
white is down two points in material but
is made up for it quite a bit in
development so a lot of times you'll see
black continue with Bishop to b4 check
trying to gain a tempo as he develops
his pieces from here white can simply
move his Knight to c3 blocking if at any
time black captures white can recapture
with his Bishop keep him on when you do
play this opening bishops are an
integral part of the game so you
definitely don't want to sacrifice your
bishops early on because from the
beginning the
those are kind of your power pieces in
any open game you want Bishop's
overnights and in a closed game with
pawns all over the board you'd rather
have a Knights they can kind of move
around but since this game is obviously
open we've already taken off three of
our pawns
we definitely want to be using bishops
and not Knight so that's why we are
going to put our knight and block it
instead of putting our bishop and
blocking it because if we were to do
that and we sacrifice then our attacking
lines just aren't as good and blacks up
the material so from here it's actually
said that blacks best move is pawn to d6
basically opening up an area for his
other bishop and then why it's going to
go ahead and challenge this bishop here
on b4 and when he does that it's going
to do two things first thing he's
attacking this bishop and the second
thing he is unleashed a powerful attack
on this f7 score we have already doubled
up on this long diagonal looking at this
big attack on the blacks King so a lot
of times from here black will go ahead
instead of running losing tempo he will
go ahead and take a pee since he has he
is up in material any time you're up in
material you'd like to sacrifice all the
way down because your advantage becomes
more clear so he will go ahead and take
and why it's going to go ahead and take
with his Bishop on c3 and if you look at
it White has a huge huge spatial
advantage here we are attacking the f7
Square we're attacking the g7 square and
if you look at it White has a lot of
different attacks that he has he has
good center control with his pawn here
he has some great attacks coming to the
King side and black really has done
nothing for his development so you can
definitely see that although down two
points you can easily make up for that
in your attacking prowess so a lot of
times you'll see black develop we can
just look at if Knight were to try to
develop the King side give the King a
little bit more room anytime white can
come in here and capture and black can't
do a whole lot his King's going to be
moving it's going to be out of position
and for the rest of the game we're going
to go ahead and take a look at a famous
game played with the Danish gambit and
kind of look at house play dat the top
level kind of look at some of the themes
see how they match up and see some of
the ideas they had when they played it
this is a game by Joseph Henry Blackburn
birthday
and Joseph Henry was playing the white
pieces and so we will go ahead and get
into it starts out as we said pawn to e4
black responds Pawnee five white offers
up his first pawn and black accepts
white offers up another pawn black
accepts and then why gets into the
Danish gambit opening and black takes
another piece and he has now left two
points in material
white takes the pond and now black tries
to develop as we've said before checking
trying to gain a tempo White's going to
defend with his knight it's not really
the most important piece so we're going
to block with that one right now black
is going to go ahead and try to start to
free up some of his new pieces so he's
going to move pawn to d6 White's going
to challenge and start a huge attack on
the King side with his double Queen
Bishop here
Black's going to take why it's going to
take the bishop the attack we talked
about before in this game black actually
chose a different move than I showed you
he chose to start to get his queen
involved first actually don't like this
as much for black simply because white
can continue development as we'll see in
this game with well excuse me after we
take on f7 and force the King to move
then we can bring our knight into the
game forcing the Queen to move and also
gaining a tempo as we develop now when
the Queen move the Queen wants to stay
active so he moves to a better location
so he can attack this piece but why it's
not too worried he's going to go ahead
and castle and from this position you
can see that black is in a world of hurt
he's definitely up in material although
not by much at this point he's only up
by one pawn we have two pawns he has
three of ours but all of our pieces are
involved in the attack on the white side
we have a huge attack black King has
already moved this rooks not going
anywhere this rooks not going anywhere
he hasn't
moved either of his knights our rooks
already connected that's a huge thing
anytime an opening you want to connect
your rooks and so you can already tell
that blacks and a lot of trouble so
we'll go ahead and continue the game
here black tries to free up his minor
piece his night and tried to get this
Bishop out of here
white responds back to c4 he's not too
worried about it he knows that black
can't do much black is going to continue
to try to develop some of his pieces and
use them in the attack and why it's
going to go ahead and start pushing up
his pawn black is going to go ahead and
take that pawn some of the center
control blacks or White's going to go
ahead and take that and you're going to
see a sacrifice in the middle Black's
going to take Y it's going to take with
his bishop and why it still has both of
his bishops which is a key concept in
the Danish game but from what we talked
about blacks going to try to use his
Queen to attack this Bishop but for the
most part everything he does now this
kind of futile so White's going to go
ahead and defend that bishop with his
rook getting it on this open e file that
will be used later and blacks going to
try to bring his knight into the game he
had his knight on the H file usually a
knight on the edge isn't very helpful so
he tries to bring his knight into the
game and why it's going to go ahead and
just take another piece and from here
white would go on to win pretty easily
once he got his other pieces involve so
hope you enjoyed the video definitely
check out more please subscribe so you
know when other videos are coming up
and hope you enjoy